la malnutrición infantil en la región de
tigre está cerca de ser una tragedia
alimentaria así lo comunicó el fondo de
las naciones unidas para la infancia
unicef y un estado externas
unicef calcula que más de 100 mil niños
en tigre podrían sufrir desnutrición
aguda grave que pone en peligro su vida
en los próximos 12 meses un aumento de
10 veces en comparación con el número de
casos anual promedio
la zona vive una intensa en bruna
provocada por el conflicto entre el
frente de liberación popular de tigre y
el ejército de etiopía además de sus
aliados eritreos y las fuerzas
regionales de ama jara
la ayuda humanitaria al territorio es
fuertemente restringida el 17 de julio
una caravana del programa mundial de
alimentos fue atacada y actualmente se
impide el acceso de comida
unos 200 camiones están en camino ahora
de se mira a make l esto es como una
gota en el océano necesitamos que al
menos 100 camiones se dirijan todos los
días a tigre yq si queremos tener la
oportunidad de revertir la situación
catastrófica que tenemos hoy la onu
exhortó al gobierno etíope a permitir el
ingreso inmediato de la asistencia
alimentaria
una cosa que es un pedido muy concreto
que nosotros el presidente etíope es que
el gobierno debe permitir que los
trabajadores humanitarios lleven equipos
de comunicaciones adicionales y también
que proporcione visas con mayor plazo -
o provide language and listas en chivas
estamos el conflicto que explotó en
noviembre el año pasado en la agitada
región ha dejado miles de muertos y más
de 2 millones de personas desplazadas
según la onu 5.2 millones de personas
sólo en tigre necesitan asistencia
humanitaria es decir un 90 por ciento de
la población